I've literally had CEOs of companies
yell at me for 10 minutes about how bad
social media was cuz it's put democracy
on the brink of its knees and then we
would switch over to business and they
would then explain to me how social
media can't sell their product the way
that print can and I was like let me get
this stra social media is powerful
enough to put democracy on its knees but
it can't sell lipstick get the hell out
of
here I dat trade attention and build
businesses
Legacy is greater than
currency I'm a pure bread entrepreneur
for real for real for real like
documented you have one missed call from
Gary vaynerchuck would you like to play
the message why is organic social media
the most important thing in business yet
nobody's looking at
it because everyone thinks it's an
afterthought and a nice to have when it
is the foundation of the competitors
that are eating up the
ecosystem I'm writing a new book it's
called day trading attention and the
thesis is we've never been a time in
marketing in the last 100 years where
you can steal it or you can get
murdered the reason I use day trading is
there's two different ways to invest
make different big bets and you go to
sleep and you know that your grandkids
are going to be happy or unhappy with
you or you day trade and you're making
it in the margins hour by hour marketing
used to be the other way nine months you
know we're going to plan the campaign
and we're going to pray that it works
out and now it's if you are not
marketing every single day someone's
outflanking you it's hard and I'm
empathetic the hardest thing in the
world to do in marketing is social media
creative and yet it is deemed the
easiest by every organization and what
what I mean mean by that I mean it's the
thing that most people don't actually
really care
[Music]
about marketers business people sales
people like ourselves will go to a
dinner table and we will have
conversations about social media on two
fronts one how it's ruining the country
two how it's ruining our children I've
literally had CEOs of companies and they
would yell at me for 10 minutes about
how bad social media was cuz it's put
democracy on the brink of it knees and
then we would switch over to business
once we were done with our opening
cocktail and letting that person rant
and they would then explain to me how
social media can't sell their product
the way that print can and I was like
let me get this straight social media is
powerful enough to put democracy on its
knees but it can't sell lipstick get the
hell out of
here this is where you can out flag your
competitors your direct competitors the
biggest companies will take more
seriously a 30second commercial and
spend more money on the
catering of that 302nd commercial and
the t& of that 32nd commercial then
they'll spend on their entire year on
social which is why they're all so
reliant on
influencers because they don't know how
to do
it you becoming the influencer though is
the Holy Grail what I do for a living
right now is try to get you to be in a
place where you're not at the mercy of
the influencer and not at the mercy of
the celebrity and not at the mercy of
the retailer that is my obsession and
that's what needs to be your obsession
otherwise it's going to cost you more
money to do
[Music]
business